Vamos a darle un repaso general a todo lo
que hemos visto de sistemas de ecuaciones
y en este video creo que sería muy bueno
recordar todo lo que hemos aprendido acerca de,
¿cómo resolver un sistema de ecuaciones?,
¿qué tipos de sistemas de ecuaciones hay?,
o ¿cómo encontrar la solución
de un sistema de ecuaciones?,
por lo tanto, déjame copiar aquí mis dos ecuaciones
con las que voy a trabajar en este video.
Y dice, "9x" menos "4y" es igual a -78,
ésta es mi primera ecuación
y voy a tomar la siguiente ecuación,
"4x" más "y" esto voy a decir
que es igual a -18,
ya aquí tengo mis dos ecuaciones y bueno, recuerda que nosotros teníamos un sistema que es consistente
y realmente nos gustaría tener un sistema consistente,
si pasa lo siguiente.
Si nosotros vemos la gráfica de estas dos ecuaciones, son líneas rectas,
entonces vamos a intentar hacer aquí las gráficas de estas dos ecuaciones para ver
a qué me refiero con un sistema consistente.
Imagínate que aquí vamos a tener nuestros dos ejes...
déjame cambiar de color,
para hacer la gráfica de estas dos rectas...
o bueno, tal vez no la gráfica de estas dos rectas,
pero al menos como un esbozo de estas dos rectas.
Supongamos que aquí tengo mi eje de las "y",
muy bien, aquí tengo a mi eje de las "x"
y lo que esperamos es que estas dos rectas
se vean de la siguiente manera, supongamos...
vamos a suponer que ésta, así se ve la primera
recta, ojo, es un esbozo, quien sabe si realmente
se ve así, pero bueno, vamos a suponer que
esta es la gráfica de mi primera recta
y me voy a tomar la gráfica de mi segunda recta
y también vamos a suponer que es algo así,
realmente no quiero que sea
completamente real,
lo que quiero que veas es que
lo que esperamos en un sistema de ecuaciones
es que tengamos un punto de intersección,
cuando tenemos un punto de intersección ,
tenemos un sistema consistente
y tenemos una única solución,
porque este punto de intersección
es un punto que a nosotros nos interesa mucho...
voy a ponerlo con rosa para hacer más énfasis,
este punto de aquí es muy importante para nosotros,
porque este punto nos dice que satisface
ambas ecuaciones, como está en ambas rectas,
pues es el punto de intersección,
entonces cumple tanto la primera ecuación
como la segunda ecuación y por lo tanto,
es la solución de mi sistema de ecuaciones,
porque cumple ambas ecuaciones,
así que bueno, para hacer esto,
habíamos utilizado varios métodos,
el método gráfico, sustitución, suma y resta, igualación,
sin embargo, en esta ocasión quiero verlo por el método de eliminación, por el método de suma y resta.
Así que para esto lo que quiero hacer es
eliminar la "y" y fíjate que lo que necesitamos
es que en la ecuación de abajo,
aparezca un "4y" para que ese se elimine con el "-4y"
de la ecuación de arriba,
así que voy a multiplicar la ecuación de abajo por 4.
Y me queda 4 por "4x" es "16x",
4 por "y" es "4y" y -18 por 4, lo cual es -72.
Muy bien, lo único que hice fue multiplicar
la ecuación de abajo por 4,
¿por qué?
Porque si ahora yo escribo aquí la ecuación
de arriba, la primera ecuación,
entonces ya voy a poder trabajar
con estas dos ecuaciones...
déjame ponerlo aquí...
"9x" menos "4y" es igual a 78 negativo,
a -78 y es que esto es muy importante porque
aquí ya tengo dos ecuaciones,
las cuales cuando yo las sume,
voy a poder eliminar la variable "y".
Utilizando el método de suma y resta,
se elimina la "y",
¿y qué me queda?
"16x" más "9x" es lo mismo que "25x",
muy bien, después más "4y" menos "4y" se eliminan,
se van, esto se cancela, es "0y", por lo tanto
voy a poner 0, más 0 y esto es igual a -72
menos 78, entonces si son positivo se volvería
80 más 70, 150, -150,
entonces estos dos me dan -150
y ya tengo una ecuación con solamente una incógnita,
una ecuación bien fácil de resolver,
"25x" es igual a 150 negativo...
ojo, no olvidemos el menos...
Y ahora le voy a dividir todo entre 25...
entre 25...
¿y qué me va a quedar?
25 y 25 se van, estos dos se eliminan...
ojo, no olvidemos el menos...
y aquí me queda -6,
150 entre 25 es 6
y con este menos es -6,
"x" vale -6.
Y bueno, una vez que ya
tengo el valor de "x",
pues ahora vamos a investigar
cuál es el valor de "y".
Y para eso voy a utilizar
la ecuación de acá abajo,
con la ecuación de acá abajo
voy a sustituir el valor de "x",
para poder despejar a "y".
Y me queda,
4 por -6 porque "x" vale -6,
más "y" es igual a -18.
4 por -6,
pues esto es lo mismo que 24 en negativo,
-24 más "y" es igual a -18 y ahora si yo
sumo 24 de ambos lados de la ecuación
me queda que "y" es igual a 24 menos 18,
lo cual es 6 positivo.
Es decir, que ya tengo la solución de este
sistema de ecuaciones,
cuando "x" vale -6, y "y" vale 6,
tengo la solución de este sistema de ecuaciones
o dicho de otra manera,
el punto -6, 6
es el punto de intersección de estas dos rectas
y fíjate que no era este punto de aquí,
las rectas estaban un poco desplazadas
hacia abajo pero bueno, realmente lo que quería
era hacerte un esbozo de estas dos rectas
y realmente solucionar el sistema de ecuaciones...
que ya tengo aquí la solución
y por lo tanto vamos a borrar la pantalla
y vamos a hacer otro ejercicio.
A ver, tomémonos...
la siguiente...
el siguiente par de ecuaciones...
me voy a tomar la ecuación, "-7x"
y a esto le voy a restar "-4y"
y voy a decir que esto es igual a 9,
esta es mi primera ecuación,
vamos a cambiar de color...
Y mi segunda ecuación es "x"...
más "2y" y esto voy a decir
que es igual a 3.
Y ahora si, me voy a preguntar,
¿cuál es la solución de este sistema de ecuaciones?
Y pues bueno, a mi me gusta mucho
el método de suma y resta, así que vamos a hacerlo
otra vez por suma y resta,
pero esta vez voy a eliminar a "x".
Y para eliminar a "x",
date cuenta que lo que necesito es tener un "7x"
de tal manera que cuando yo sume con este "-7x"
que tengo de la primera ecuación se cancele la "x",
por lo tanto, lo que voy a hacer es multiplicar
a la ecuación de abajo por 7,
¿y qué me queda?
"7x" más "14y" esto es igual a 21,
esto me sale de multiplicar
a la segunda ecuación por 7
y la primera ecuación la voy a poner tal cual,
"-7x" menos "4y" es igual a 9
y ahora si, vamos a sumarlas para ver qué me queda, estos dos se cancelan,
"7x" menos "7x" se van,
vámonos...
Después me queda "14y" menos "4y" es lo mismo
que "10y" y por último, 21 más 9 es 30,
lo que me dice que "y" es igual a 3,
30 entre 10 es 3 y bueno,
ahora voy a utilizar la segunda ecuación
para despejar a "x",
2 por 3 es 6 y me queda que "x" más "2y" es decir,
más 6, es igual a 3
ó dicho de otra manera "x" es igual a -3,
entonces puedo concluir que el punto
donde se intersectan estas dos rectas
es el punto -3, 3
ó la solución de este sistema de ecuaciones
es "x" igual a -3, "y" igual a 3.
Y bueno, este ejercicio estuvo muy fácil,
tan fácil que se me ocurre
hacer otro ejercicio por acá abajo,
vamos a borrar esto y vamos a copiar
el siguiente sistema de ecuaciones que dice...
me voy a tomar las ecuaciones "-3x" menos "9y"
esto lo voy a hacer igual a 66 y por otra parte tengo,
"-7x" más "4y"
esto lo voy a hacer igual a -71.
Y date cuenta que aquí no está tan fácil
eliminar a uno de estos dos términos,
lo primero que quiero que veas
es que lo voy a resolver por suma y resta,
pero por la suma y resta que yo le llamaba
por multiplicación de una constante,
es decir, que si yo quiero eliminar de aquí a la "y",
esa va a ser mi elegida
y solamente la estoy eligiendo porque
una es positiva y la otra es negativa,
entonces tengo que multiplicar la ecuación de arriba
por 4 y por otra parte, la de abajo por 9.
Y si multiplico primero la de arriba por 4 me queda,
4 por 3 es 12 menos "12x" menos "36y"
y 66 por 4 es lo mismo que 240 más 24,
que es 264.
Perfecto, "-12x" menos "36y" es igual a 264
y si yo lo que quiero es cancelar a la "y",
entonces tengo que multiplicar la de abajo por 9,
¿y qué me queda?
9 por 7 = 63, "-63x" más "36y"
es lo mismo que 9 por -71,
esto está fácil, 9 por 1= 9,
9 por 7 es 63, -639.
Perfecto y ahora si vamos a sumarlas.
¿Qué me queda?
"-12x" menos "63x" es lo mismo que "-75x".
Después aquí tengo
"-36y" más "36y" se van
y después por otra parte tengo
264 menos 639
y bueno, como ésta es más grande la
voy a poner abajo y lo voy a restar,
¿y qué me queda de la resta de estos 2?
639 menos 264
y el resultado lo pongo negativo,
9 y 4 es 5, 6 para 13 y entonces este se vuelve 5,
6 para 13 es 7 y 5 menos 2 es 3, perfecto,
pero como el negativo era más grande,
entonces me queda -375, "-75x" es igual a -375
y ahora si divido ambos lados de la ecuación entre -75,
me va a quedar que "x" es igual a...
y bueno, 75 cabe 4 veces en 300
y 5 veces en 375.
"x" es igual a 5,
perfecto.
Ya tengo el valor de "x",
ahora lo que quiero saber es el valor de "y"
y para eso voy a utilizar la primera ecuación
y voy a sustituir el valor de "x",
¿y qué me queda?
-3 por "x", pero "x" vale 5,
-3 por 5 menos "9y" es igual a 66,
es decir -15 menos "9y" es igual a 66
y ahora voy a pasar el 15 del otro lado
y me queda que "-9y" es lo mismo que 66 más 15,
que es 81 y por último,
"y" es igual a -9,
81 entre -9 me da -9
y por lo tanto el punto de intersección
de estas dos rectas es el punto 5, -9.